Bitcoin has broken out tremendously so
this is going to obviously impact the pi
cycle top indicator in a very big way
we're going to be talking about how
that's going to impact things because
we're seeing that these two Pi cycle
moving averages are lifting up and that
means a lot for the coming P Cycle
crossover but also in terms of this
being a resistance this being a support
and so much more so subscribe to the
channel for more videos like this in the
future like this video if you enjoy data
science content like this going forward
and let's dive right into it so when we
look at this P Cycle moving average
history generally speaking prior to the
harving is when we see oscillation
oscillation in and around this moving
average but as we go into the parving
year we tend to see fantastic retesting
of this py cycle moving average as a
support all the way to new alltime highs
same thing in 2019 you can see
oscillation in and around this moving
average but once we get into the Haring
year maybe one deviation to the downside
below the P Cycle moving average but
generally speaking retesting as a
support even deviating to the upside
Beyond this support and not actually
retesting it until New all-time highs so
those are two really important things to
note when it comes to the P Cycle moving
average because we are now transitioning
into the Haring year 2024 we're
transitioning out from the preh Haring
year of 2023 where we did see lots of
oscillation and Dev ation Beyond it
holding as support deviation right over
here fantastic successful retest as you
can see right over here picked your
perfect retest and now that we're
deviating and getting out of 2023 in
2024 the best we can hope for is a
retest of this P Cycle moving average
going forward deviations below it are
going to be less likely but what about
the upside when it comes to the upside
we've seen in 2019 for instance
rejection from this green move moving
average and then another rejection right
over here but a much shallower and
weaker one before finally breaking
Beyond it and in 2016 in the harving
year we also got close to the green
moving average right over here rejected
quite harshly but once we got back there
we broke beyond it quite nicely so the
key Insight here is that when we are
approaching the green moving average we
reject from there quite strongly on the
first time of asking on the second time
of asking it's a shallow retrace if a
retrace at all and we've seen that in
2019 as well rejection sharp rejection
shallow rejection on the second time of
asking in the Haring year so if we do
get close to this moving average right
over here then we will probably reject
from there if we indeed get close to it
on this move not a given and if we do
get close to it later down the line in
the harving year because that's where we
could see a rejection once we get there
in the year then there could be a sort
of pullback and then a recovery back
into this moving average and then a
break on a second time of asking but
going forward where could we see a
retest for the P Cycle moving average
where could Bitcoin drop into and retest
the P Cycle moving average well that
would be at 31k which makes complete
sense because if we look at this Range
High Resistance remember this was the
range back in the day Range High
Resistance range low support and if we
drop back into the top of that Range
High Resistance just to turn it into a
new support well there you have a a pi
cycle retest waiting to happen unlikely
we'll get a downside deviation in the
Haring year right over here because that
is not what we see in terms of trend
historical trend for the P Cycle moving
average in prehab is yes we do see
downside deviations but in the future
very unlikely and if we do see one
happen it would go against history but
the same time it would represent a
fantastic buy side opportunity but what
about the upside the upside is around
55k could we get to 55k this year it's
uh unlikely unlikely simply because we
have a 4year cycle resistance around 48k
region but 55k could be Revisited in the
Haring year and could prompt some
rejection and then after we recover from
that rejection which could be quite deep
we could see another second revisit and
then we'd break Beyond it quite
comfortably so at this point in the
cycle what do things look like because
we have the P Cycle moving average 111
days moving average here which is
representing 31k at this price point we
have the multiplier of that moving
average
350 time 2 I believe as we can see here
350 day moving average time 2 which is a
multiplier and we're seeing these two
moving averages they are C clearly going
towards the upside especially this one
this one is the more sensitive moving
average because it takes into account
less days as you can see here the orange
moving average 111 day moving average
and that's much less days to take into
account as a result it's more sensitive
to moves in price action we've been
moving quite a lot in recent weeks which
is why this moving average is going to
change very rapidly very quickly because
it's highly sensitive to it and this is
going to be changing a little bit slower
but we have to understand that these
strong moves aren't common in the past
year for instance we generally had a lot
of consolidation very few breakout moves
in general and it's only recently that
we've seen such a move up and the reason
I mentioned that is that this move up is
really distorting this P Cycle quite
substantially so if we do try to bring
these lines and propel them into the
future future and try to come up with a
date where we could see these P Cycle
moving averages cross over into a
bearish crossover to Mark the bull
market Peak then we come up with
December
2024 and the reason we have to take this
with a pinch of salt and in fact a
bigger bigger than a pinch of salt is
because we're going to see Corrections
in the market and when we do see
Corrections the slope of this P Cycle
moving average is simply going to change
and it's going to slope downwards which
is going to drastically impact this
crossover and these propelled lines the
green moving average isn't going to be
affected too much by the retraces simply
because it takes into account more days
and is less sensitive but it's this
moving average that is going to be
constantly changing along with the
volatility in price action so if we do
see a rejection in the coming weeks then
we're probably going to tilt towards the
downside and then that would as a result
change things quite
considerably because small tilts can
change the target date by a few months
and that's where the sensitivity of this
pie cycle moving average can be a
problem when trying to come up with
where could we see a bearish crossover
and the P Cycle moving averages occur in
the future to denote a bull market top
for Bitcoin so really important to
understand that these volatile
deviations in price action are going to
adversely and strongly affect this
sensitive P Cycle moving average so we
are going to see things really
essentially the P Cycle moving average
is going to essentially suggest to us
that we could even see maybe a bull
market peak in September if things
continue to the upside like this because
that's going to mean that this P Cycle
moving average is going to continue to
drag up and if we were to propel this
moving average once again then we could
actually get closer to an October
bearish crossover so it's really
important to understand that at this
point in the cycle these two moving
averages are very wide apart from each
other and they're going to continue to
be wide but at some point especially
after the harving this blue vertical
line just showcases to us that then
we're going to see these moving averages
narrow and narrow and narrow with time
until that crossover finally occurs but
in my personal opinion I don't think
we're going to end we're not going to
end the bull market in 2024 December I
feel like we're going to end it later in
2025 maybe September maybe October mid
September and mid October not in
December 2024 and we're going to see
further upside in Bitcoin and then
downside and consolidation and then
upside and pullbacks and that's going to
be impacting this P Cycle moving average
quite
considerably but in the meantime I
wouldn't worry about December 2024 being
that ultimate sell side zone for the
bull market Peak I feel like we're going
to see this crossover change so many
times in the meantime as we progress in
this bull market but subscribe to the
channel just to stay a breast of of
these updates keep in touch and check
out these videos just to be on top of
the market to know when to sell into
strength in the bull market Peak because
that's what we're going to be sharing
here in these data science videos once
this bearish crossover does occur in the
future subscribe to the channel for more
videos like this in the future like this
video if you enjoy data science content
like this going forward check out the
top right hand corner for more and I'll
speak to you in the next one speak to
you soon